okay
someone Marcus up okay great so hi there
good morning
um my name is Santa Monica I'm a
principal Cloud architect working for uh
info Sport with an article cell C
company in the Netherlands
um really glad to be here it is actually
my first time here at NDC London so
um yeah really excited so the topic of
today is actually going to be two topics
we're going to talk about Dapper we're
going to talk about Azure container apps
and especially how we can combine these
two technologies into this really
powerful flexible surface platform for
our New York 10 wise applications
now I've been working with a customer in
Netherlands for quite some time now
they're a company in the energy utility
sector and they have a growing number of
Nets microservices
which they run most of them anyway in
Azure app services and generally
speaking they are actually quite happy
with that app Services really easy to
get to learn is easy to deployer.net
applications to write now over the last
couple of years they've been starting
using containers more and more they
really like the uh the portability and
the isolation it gives them but it's
still deployed those containers to a
sharp services and you can do that with
this web app for containers feature
so even though they are quite happy with
this
um there are some downsides because as
you have Services it's really optimized
for running web applications right
um so it's optimized for running one or
maybe a couple of containers really well
and they're not just building web
applications they are building these
large Microsoft Solutions consisting of
many moving parts and so ideally they'd
like to have access to some more
advanced features more geared towards
microservices things like
traffic routing and service Discovery
things you really want when you need
where you get a lot of more different
microservices
they also like to have some better skill
out capabilities you can scale out of
course with Azure app servers but if you
do you scale out the entire app service
plan and I like to have some more fine
more granular control over that
so if they were building microservices
and if they want all of these nice
features then why not just go to
kubernetes right because it will do all
of that for you well there are very
hesitant to go to kubernetes because
frankly they don't need all the
flexibility that kubernetes will offer
them and they basically don't want any
of the complexity that's give me this
will give them because let's face it
kubernetes even on a servers like Azure
kubernetes servers where a lot of it is
meant is for you is still a way more
complex service to use than Azure app
servers and that's simply because it
does a lot more
um
so you get this higher complexity so
they are
a bit Stuck in the Middle Here app
Services doesn't offer them enough
kubernetes gives them basically too much
and as you might have guessed this is
where I should container apps comes into
the picture so with container apps we
get basically the Surplus platform that
we can use to run our continuous
workloads
um it still uses kubernetes under the
hood but you don't have to deal with all
of the lower level implementation
details so you don't have to deal with
that kubernetes API directly instead you
work with this opinionated highly high
level of abstraction that still gives
you Advanced features like a traffic
routing and HTTP increase and search
Discovery without having you go to that
kubernetes layer directly
so basically you are trading some of the
flexibility that you get with kubernetes
for a lot more Simplicity and ease of
use
so this is basically perfect fit for
them because now they can simply focus
on building those microservice
applications they still get some of
those Advanced features they want
without having to worry about many of
those implementation details
so there currently evaluating whether or
not this is really a good fit for them
um it's still fairly new Azure container
apps and they're doing some proof of
Concepts now unfortunately I cannot show
those to you today but I do have this
other sample which we can use to further
explore Azure container apps and also
look into Dapper and this is my perfect
control sample so you've probably got
this also here in the UK in the
Netherlands we have a lot of these speed
control trajectories where you use
cameras above the roads to snap pictures
of your car at least of your license
plate and then at the start with the
trajectory they take a picture and then
at the end they take a picture they can
calculate your average speed and then of
course if you've driven too fast you'll
get a fine a hefty fine I should say
um so if we want to automate it
I have this solution which consists of
three main services
so first of all we have the charge
control servers this is the surface that
will receive the events from the camera
and it is responsible for
um calculating that average speed and
then determining whether or not there
was a speeding violation
so if it detects a speeding violation it
will write you out and it will tell it's
to the Fine Collection servers Define
collection surface then responsible for
calculating the exact fine amount and
sending you an email with the speeding
ticket now in order to be able to do
that it needs some more information
which it can get from the vehicle
registration servers so
these three services are the main
Services there are a couple of more but
we'll cut into that later
now if I want to deploy this solution to
Azure container apps the first thing
that I have to do is create an Azure
container apps environment and then
inside this environment these
microservice will run inside its own
Azure container app
so for those of you know kubernetes
Azure container apps basically just I
could need this ball right so it can run
one or more containers and it's the unit
of scale so each of these container apps
you can scale and deploy individually
now if I want to do a demo for this we
obviously need some data right because
otherwise it would be a boring demo
um I don't have any access to traffic
cameras at least not at the moment so
I've got the next best thing which is
the simulator it will simulate some cars
driving by on a road it will generate
those entry and exit events and it will
push them to need to have control
servers and I will be using mqtt for
that that's a really lightweight
measuring protocol which is pretty often
used in iot scenarios
so where does Debra fit into all of this
because up to now we've only talked
about ACA I'm going to call it ACA by
the way because ash container actual
Cuts it's a bit long-winded so Deborah
can make it a lot easier for us to
implement this Microsoft solution
Dapper originated within Microsoft as an
open source project it's a couple of
years old now I think it's about three
years old something like that it's also
been adapted by the senior CF
what it basically is it's this set of
micro server of building blocks that
makes it easier for you to create
microservice Solutions or distributed
systems so there's a lot of different
building blocks in here and what's nice
about these building blocks is that
almost all of them are pluggable so you
can use different types of components
with them so as an example let's take
the State Management building block so
State Management allows you to create
these stateful Services by allowing you
to store key value pairs in some
underlying data store and there are many
different components that you can choose
from so I could choose a component that
stores my data let's say in Azure table
storage and then later if I change my
mind maybe I want to switch to mongodb I
can use a mongodb component and I don't
need to change my code it's only the
component configuration that I need to
change
so that means that the price application
of a reportable very easy to move
between different environments
what's also very interesting about
Dapper is the way that you use these
from your application so Dapper is not a
library or a framework that you have to
link inside your application as compile
time stuff like that instead you talk to
it using the Dapper API which has two
flavors HTTP and grpc
um
and then your application runs in its
own process so if I'm running this on my
local development machine there's two
processes running side by side my
application and the Dapper runtime and I
talk of this API
now if you are running this in
production the deputy actually
recommends that you run it in kubernetes
so that would mean that I have a
container with my application code and I
have a container I did a preside car
container running adapter runtime and
those would run together in a single
part
um
so this site for architecture is really
interesting because this means that
you basically can use any language right
because any language that can make an
HTTP or a grpc call can work with those
Dapper building blocks so that makes it
really flexible especially in larger
Microsoft scenarios where you maybe have
different teams working with different
languages and Technologies
all right so normally if I want to use
Debra I would spin a micro Mini's
cluster for production and I need to
deploy deeper into it but with Azure
container apps Dapper is basically built
in out of the box so the only thing we
need to do is to specify on a container
app that we want to use Dapper enable it
and then Azure container apps will
inject the depot sidecar for us now this
is not a nothing all thing I've enabled
it here for all three services because I
want to use Dapper in all three of my
services but you can also enable it for
a single surface or two out of three
all right so
let's switch gears for a moment
and see what that actually looks like in
the Azure portal
if it's still running because
um great timing but more uh this morning
there were some issues in azure
um I tried it all out it still worked
this morning so I I hope it's still
working now
um yeah so let's start in visual studio
so
um this fee is code with my solution it
says um fist ball in the back just okay
yeah awesome
so I deploy this solution to Azure using
bicep so here my deploy folder let's see
where's my cursor
um there's a lot of bicep modules and if
we dig here in here into some folders
then for example here is the bicep
module for the turf control surface
which that service that will receive the
camera events so this takes in some
parameters we have the locations of the
region where we want to deploy this we
have the
um this is deploying a single edge
container app right so we need to know
the ID of their environment where we
want to deploy that app into
then I also have this Menace identity ID
so this is the name of a user assigned
minus identity that I created to let my
app integrate with some other Azure
resources
and then down here on line 9 we can see
the actual resource definition of the
container app
now we need to give the name we need to
give you that location I assigned that
minus identity and then we get to the
properties
where I'll set the environment ID and
then finally here in the template
section we can specify which container
we actually want to run inside this app
which is a container that I pull for my
public Docker Hub repo thingy
now notice this is an array
So within a container app you can run
multiple containers and that's the skill
unit so they will scale together
but as far as scaling goes I'm keeping
it simple for now so here I specify that
I want to have basically exactly one
replica and we will not do any odd
scaling yet but we'll get to that
and then finally in configuration
I need to study active Refrigeration
smart so what's a revision well a
revision is basically
um immutable snapshot of a version of
your application so let's say that I've
got this great new feature in my
application but I only want 20 of the
requests coming in to use that new
feature just to try it out like doing a
little Canary testing then I can set the
active refusions mode to multiple and
then I can add traffic rules so that 20
of the traffic will go to the latest
revision and 80 of the traffic will go
to the older refusion now in this case
I'm simply using a single revisions mode
which means that 100 of the incoming
traffic will always go to the very
latest version of my app that I've
deployed
and then finally on online 34 we get to
the depth apart so here I enable the
upper to inject that sidecar each Dapper
app also needs to have a unique ID
that's the debr application ID so I set
the two turf control servers and then
this Dapper sidecar needs to know on
which Port my application is listening
because most of the time I'm calling the
preside car but sometimes the Dapper
software needs to call into my
application for example to get some
configuration or to trigger my
application to start doing something so
my app is simply running on Port 80.
now I've already deployed this
um so we don't have to wait
so here I am in the Azure portal in the
dev turf control ACI Resource Group so
here we can see the container apps
environment you can see some container
apps here like defined collection
servers and you can actually see a lot
of more stuff
um which is all stuff I need and we'll
catch you but let me first jump into
this turf control surface
and you can see that if I go to Deborah
you can see that it is enabled and
there's all those settings we just saw
in the bicep module and if I scroll down
you can even see all the Dapper
components that are configured for this
app
and what's really nice and useful for
debugging and for these kinds of demos
is that you could go to the lock stream
it's always a weird alert because I
didn't change anything it still wants me
to I guess discard nothing
um so here you can see the direct output
coming from the containers in your app
so as you'll see the latest lock line is
from like uh nine o'clock this morning
at nine o'clock this still works at
least
so this shows all of the Locking of all
of the containers in your app right so
this is my application container but
because there's also a sidecar
containing running there I can also
select oh select that Sidecar
and we will see the Dapper logs so this
is really
um useful to get a nice live view of
what is happening inside your
application all of that blocking is also
dumped into a lock analytics workspace
so if you want to do some uh longer term
query stuff like that you can use log
analytics for that
all right for now let's
go back to the slides
and let's dive a little deeper into our
first surface of traffic control servers
so this needs to get some data from the
traffic simulator right and to keep the
service itself nicely decoupled from the
cameras and or my simulator I'm going to
use a mqtt message progress in middleman
here so I'm going to use mosquito which
is this very lightweight mqtt open
source message broker
and what we'll do is the traffic
simulator can push messages to Mosquito
and then other clients like the traffic
control servers can subscribe to process
those messages right so it works just
like any message broker
um but of course mosquito is running
inside of azure somewhere up there
and my traffic simulator is going to run
on my local laptop so we need to make
sure those two can connect and the way
to do that is to set up increase on that
container app so we're setting up
increase you're basically exposing a
port to make it available to to the
clients now in this case I'm talking
mqtt and mqtt is a DSP based protocol so
I need to open up a TCP port and usually
with mqtt that's 1883 that's usual
report that's used for that
so I can do that using this piece of
bicep here you can see I've added a
Ingress part to My configuration section
setting external to True means that I
want that port to be available outside
of my environment if I leave it at False
only the other services within these
environments can access the port
uh so the target ports deported and want
to expose are my mosquito container the
exposed Port is supported the clients
going to connect to uh that is optional
by default it's to the Target Port but
you can do some Port mapping there if
you like
um and then I need to specify the
transport tab now originally ACA only
supported HTTP and HTTP 2 and now TCP
increase is in public preview so I'm
using the preview feature there is one
kefir dial you have to deploy your Azure
container environment inside a custom
v-net for this to work so what I did for
my bicep modules I first created that
custom v-net and then I deployed that
environment into that v-net and now I
can use tsp so this works great so now I
have my events generated going up to
Mosquito and now the traffic control
service needs to process those events
but house is going to do that
so we're talking mqtt here so I'm I
could go hunt for mqtt nuket Library
injected into my application deal with
it directly from my code or I could
simply not worry about mqtt at all and
just let Dapper handle that
and we can do that by using a building
block called Dapper bindings or in this
case specifically the input bindings
so with deeper bindings
um you can basically interface with
external systems without having to worry
about all of the lower nitty-gritty
details so what we can do is we can
create a component configuration for a
mqtt Dapper input binding then the
sidecar will see that component it will
subscribe to Mosquito for us and it will
start to receive those messages and then
when a message comes in
it will trigger the application
by calling a HTTP endpoint on the
application now notice it's an HTTP now
the mqtt endpoint and we can create very
simply an HTTP endpoint because well
basically we're doing that all of the
time so now my application doesn't need
to deal it doesn't even need to know
that it's using mqtt under the hood it
only needs to expose that HTTP endpoint
and that's also really nice for um
testing by the way
so
let's see that in code let's first look
at that component configuration file
so let me open up
this again uh where did I put this
inside my depth folder so there are two
input bindings here actually so the
entry cam is for the first set of
cameras that your car will drive under
um so what we see here on line eight is
the the deeper components for this so
each stepper component needs to have a
name so I'm going to call this entry cam
and then you need to specify the
component type so this is a binding for
mqtt so buy mixer time qtt by the way
there are a lot of components there are
I think they've they're up to like a 124
components something like that over all
of the building blocks so
and you can contribute your own if
you're missing something because it's
all open source
um
and then in this metadata part here you
need to specify the metadata for the
component and the the exact stuff that
you need to specify of course differs
per component type so in this case for
mqtt we need to tell it
um where the mqtt host is by specifying
this URL parameter we need to tell it
what topic we want to subscribe to so
for the entry can we want to listen to
the entry cam messages and then each
client that connects to Mosquito needs
to have a unique ID we don't know
exactly how many clients are coming to
be because if I scale out I will get
multiple clients right so instead of
having a static value here I just use
this nice template syntax
which means hey Debra you figure it out
just generate a unique ID for me a free
time you create an instance of this
component
and then finally we get to discuss parts
so by default every Dapper component
that I Define is available to every
Azure container app running in that
environment you may not want that you
may want to scope it further to a single
serve so to a set of services so you can
do that using this using these scopes
so with this set up Deborah will start
listening to using this URL to this
topic
and then it will alert my application
whenever
there is a message available so if I
look at each control servers
I have these nice minimal API endpoints
I really like minimal API for doing
demos like this because everything is
nice in a single file so I've got two of
them entry Cam and exit Cam and these
are the end points that we'll get calls
whenever a message comes in so how does
stepper know that I've named these
endpoints entry Cam and exit cam well
that's pretty simple if you just go back
to the um findings it's the name of the
binding so if I change this name here I
also need to change the name of that
after the endpoint and I also have exit
Game binding which is exactly the same
the only difference is it's called
access game and it listens to a
different topic
um
let's see what we'll do yeah we'll go
back to the slides for a bit
um and talk about uh Auto scaling just a
bit because now that we've decoupled
stuff with that mosquito broker it's
very easy to scale out the trash control
servers to start processing more
messages in in parallel and Azure
container actually uses Keda for that so
Keda is a kubernetes event Driven Auto
scaler it's a different open source
project which they've incorporated into
Azure container apps and we can use
skida to create rules like this one so
this is a really simple rule it's based
on CPU utilization it just says a
minimum replicas one maximum three and
if you're really busy go spin up another
replica right so this is a pretty boring
one but keeda has a lot of different
scalers that you can use so for example
if I were pulling in messages from a
service bus queue
then there's a service bus scaler for
key data that I could use and then I can
scale my app based on the number of
messages in the queue now unfortunately
there isn't a mqtt scaler yet for uh
kedia otherwise I would be able to use
that and we could Scale based on the
number of messages available in mosquito
so I'm just sticking with this CPU rule
for now so
if the CPU load is high enough
eventually we will get two three
replicas right notice here that I'm
still only have a single app and within
that app I have three replicas all
processing messages in parallel now the
very nice thing about ACA is that you
can also scale down all the way down to
zero and zero is great because if there
is no work to do I don't want to pay for
it and I can just shut it all off
but
while that's really nice be really
careful with this if you are using
Dapper to trickle your application as
I'm doing here because if your scaled
down to zero of course your application
container is gone but your sidecar
container is also gone
and the sidecar container was the only
component in my diagram that actually
triggers my application to do some work
so we decided for container gun nobody
subscribed to that mosquito topic
anymore and nothing will ever happen
again this will always stay at zero
now if we did have access to a keeda
scaler for mqtt we could have used that
then the scalar would detect hey there
is some work to be done because I see a
q count higher than one and it will
scale my application back up so that
would get us out of this problem but
because here Dapper is the only one
triggering and I don't have a scalar
based on the infrastructure I shoot nuts
definitely not scale down this solution
to zero
um
yeah okay so now we get in those camera
events so just to reiterate we get an
entry message that has a timestamp when
a car reaches the first set of cameras
then after a while unless something
horribly happens the car will reach the
exit and we get a different time step
and then we can calculate the effort
speech right so the time step that we
get at the point of entry we need to at
least keep somewhere safe on until at
least we get to the to the end of the
trajectory so this needs to be a
stateful server
and to do that I can use another adapter
building block called State Management
so it's State Management I can simply
store key value pairs inside some data
store to be determined configured now
this really meant for like hot state or
transactional state small things like
this don't replace your huge relational
SQL database with States management
that's not what it's meant for
so I'm going to use this to store my
state in Azure Cosmos DB so to set it up
I create another component configuration
file for that customer sdb and then when
I want to either save some state or get
some State I make a call to my deposite
car tell it what I want then the depth
sidecar will look at the configuration
and it will talk to Azure customers to
be for me right
now the nice thing about this being all
blockable and portable is that if I run
this Solution on my laptop maybe I don't
want to be tied to Azure maybe Azure is
down like this morning
and then maybe I want to use redis for a
state store because I can run redis in a
container on my laptop
in that case I only need to change that
components configuration file Deborah
will use red as Mi application code can
stay exactly the same I don't need to
change anything
so again that's really flexible I'm
going to stick with Azure Cosmos DB for
now while it's whilst working
so
after we've done that we now have the
speeding violation and we need to tell
the fan collection service about it and
I'm going to do that asynchronously by
publishing an event and of course
there's another building block to help
me with that called the publisher
subscribe or Pub sub building block and
that allows me to integrate with message
brokers
so in this case I'm going to use another
component configuration to set up a
connection to an Azure service bus and
then when I want to publish that event I
simply go into my debit Sidecar
so
let me show you what that all looks like
in code so let's go back to official
Studio code and basically
continue where we left off we were in
the traffic control servers with these
two endpoints right
so
um this is the first one the entry camp
so the only thing that we actually have
to do here is store that entry State
until some later time when we reach the
end of the trajectory so I'm going to
create a new vehicle set object with
just a simple container object or I
think it's a record actually with a
couple of properties so I'm going to new
that up and then I need to use Dapper to
save that state now there are a couple
of ways to do that I could simply use an
HTTP client and make a direct HTTP call
to that sidecar because it's an HTTP API
but it's much nicer to use one of the
language specific sdks and there are a
lot of them of course there's C sharp so
I'm using the net SDK but there are sdks
for python Java rusts go I think PHP
even JavaScript a lot of languages
so to use this SDK I've added a new cat
package to this
project and then up here at line number
four you can see me calling a Dapper
client so that register some Client
Services into the services collection
which in turn allows me to in this
Handler here inject aw client and I can
use that type of client object to
interact with my sidecar so it exposes
stuff like Save State and then in Save
State I can pass in the name of the
component that I want to use which is
state store so if we go back to device
and modules and we look at state store
here is my state store component you can
see it has the right name it's of type
Cosmos DB and then I have some metadata
to tell there how to connect to the
actual customers to be now notice that
for the master key I have it put it in
here in plain text because this will get
pushed up to GitHub and it's no fun
pushing your secrets up to GitHub so
instead I'm using a secret reference
which references this Secret store here
which is not a Dapper building block
which will get into later
so the other parameters here uh are the
key that I won't store any value that I
want store and then I'm done Dapper does
all of the hard work for me I didn't
need to use any customers DB specific
code or sdks here that's all being done
by dapper
now as soon as we reach the end of the
trajectory we get an exit message
the first thing I need to do is to
retrieve that entry state from the state
store so I can use the Dapper client
again call Cat State entry
um
we should have that state right because
Africa should have come through the
entry camera before reaching the exit
but this is all still software so I'm
checking anyway so if I don't have it I
just return and not found if I have
found it I'll update that state with the
exit timestamp and just save feedback
for good measure and then we can do the
useful businessy stuff we can use the
calculator to determine whether or not
we have a traffic violation on our hands
and so we get back the speeding
violation kilometers per hour so if
that's a positive number then we'll just
go ahead and create that event that we
want to publish our speeding file is
detected which contains a bunch of
information like the license number the
road and the actual violation and we can
publish that again simply by using that
the client
so
sorry
at this point
it would be nice to see something
running
um
but unfortunately
we need to have a little talk about this
because here I'm running into
um
what I think is it's a pretty big
limitation of container apps at the
moment so I have this what I think is a
very nice visual simulator that I've
spent way too much time on and it can
generate that traffic and it creates
those events and it wants to send those
events to Mosquito of mqtt right
unfortunately
my official simulator is running inside
a browser so I'm in a browser sandbox
and I want to create a direct TCP
connection to some mqtt port on the
internet and that's the point where the
browser says no you are not allowed to
do that now fortunately mosquito has a
solution for that
we can use
mqtt of a websocket
and the way to set it up is you create a
second listener in mosquito it that
usually use the sport 901
and then from my browser I am allowed to
create a websockets connection of 901 so
I can stream nqtt over websockets to
Mosquito that will work and then the
double sidecar can still use the direct
mqtt connection so everything works out
fine
unless
we're only allowed to open up a single
port out of ACA
so this is a real bummer and it doesn't
even matter if you're uh if you want to
expose a port to other internal services
or to the outside world it's just you
get one port one Ingress so that that's
little uh snippet of bicep code I've
shown you with the inquest I would
really like that to be an array but but
it's not so I can only choose between
one of these Sports and that's simply
not good enough
um so what to do here
um well I do have this other simulator
which is a console application so it
doesn't have any
um
any sandbox it's running in it can't
just talk mqtt to that endpoint so that
will work
but it's just not as nice as the
official ones I really like that that
upper one so I'm going to over engineer
a solution out of this I'm going to just
add a whole different application which
will act as a bridge all right so I can
create an HTTP endpoint that's my visual
simulator you can talk to and then
my simulation Gateway can talk to that
same mqtt endpoint I can use adapter
output binding for that so I still don't
need to program mqtt stuff myself but
this is just a way around that
limitation for now
notice by the way that my simulation
Gateway is simply running on Port 80.
and that I'm exposing an https ports to
the outside world that's because of this
very nice feature that ACA has it can do
TLS termination for me so application
can actually actually the application
tries to connect to the ictp port by
default SEO will redirect it to the
https Port then do TLS termination and
then call my container
so this should work
emphasis on Shield so
let's
um let's see
so somewhere in this solution is my
visual simulation yeah I actually don't
need to code or I can show you the code
really quick actually
um
no not this one I meant to show you the
code for the simulation Gateway
which is this
so this just consists of these two
endpoints
these are called by the official
simulation and the only thing I need to
do is invoke that Dapper binding to just
push everything through to Mosquito and
I can simply reuse those existing entry
game and exit Game components that I've
already cut set up
now I'm going to start this visual
simulation with just a
net application hosting a website for me
and then should be able to go to Port
and we have these nice cars driving
around on the road
um so we can follow them a bit
see if they reach the exit maybe two
miles so we can see your trajectory so
while they are driving underneath these
cameras events will be generated and
pushed up to that surface
um and actually what I'm going to do
because as soon as I do this the
animation stops and it stops generating
events so just to keep the flow going
I need to keep that window at least
somewhat visible so I'm just going to
put it slightly behind
here and this will work so now if we
start out because this is timed out but
if we connect back to the logs oh and I
want to connect to the turf control
servers
you can see the entry and the exit
events going by and if you have really
sharp eyesights you can also see some
speeding violations in there but they
tend to scroll by pretty quickly so this
is working great the simulation is going
through that simulation Gateway it's
going through mosquito and is pushing it
up into this traffic control surface
all right
um
let's pause this for a minute here
and let's talk about the next
surface on our list
which is the Fine Collection servers so
the traffic control service has done its
thing it can detect spinning violation
and it publishes a speeding file as an
event whenever it encounters one and
then the Fine Collection Service needs
to subscribe to those events and do
something with it
um so this works in the same way as the
input binding did so you may say hey
isn't there some kind of Outlet why
aren't you using the pub sub building
block for the mqtt Gateway that would be
a fair question so there is some overlap
between Bunnings and Pub sub the main
difference is that uh bindings don't
care about message Brokers so you may
create a binding for message broker but
it doesn't have to be a message broker
so bindings can
integrate with all kinds of things
whereas the pub sub message block really
has to work with message Brokers and
because of that higher level of
abstraction it provides a little bit
more features like message duplication
and
routing and tracing and to provide those
features it needs to wrap those messages
inside a cloud events envelope
now I don't care about Cloud events at
the side of the cameras the cameras
don't know about the cloud defense
formats I just want to work with raw
basic payloads so that's why I'm using
bindings on that side and the pops up
building block here to integrate between
services
but it works basically the same way if
you set this up so you subscribe to some
topic on the edge service bus and then
whenever a message comes in the deposit
code will trick my application to do the
actual processing of that message
um
let's look at that processing so we need
to calculate an exact file amount so
let's say that we use some common of the
Shelf products called find kelp to do
that for us and in order to use fine
calc we need to have a license key to
bank help because it's a commercial
product so I need to store that license
key somewhere safe it's basically a
secret right that I need to store
somewhere
now there are two ways I can store this
so first of all
ACA itself has a secret store which
simply uses the underlying kubernetes
Secret store and this is really great if
you want to like reference those secrets
from scaling rules so you have a service
bus scaling rule which needs a
connection string to the service bus you
can put that inside of ACI Secrets but
it's not so great if you want your
Dapper applications to be portable
because I'm I also want to be able to
run this Solution on my laptop right and
then I'm not running inside of ACA so I
don't have access to any building Secret
store of ACA so I want to have something
else and that's something else that's of
course a building block in this case
there are secrets management so I can
set up a component
to talk to a Secret store which in this
case is going to be Azure key fault
and then whenever my app needs access to
a secret it can just again just like
with only build other building blocks it
can make a request to the sidecar and it
will cut the secret from the key fold
and then if I run it locally on my
application most of the time I simply
use a Dapper or a Secret store component
that stores secrets in like environment
variables or a Json files stuff that's
easy to test with
okay so now we can get the license key
we can call fine calc so we get the fine
amounts then we're just about ready to
send the email but in order to do that
we need some more information on the
vehicle and on the vehicle owner
specifically we need to know the email
address of the vehicles owner and we can
get that information from the vehicle
registration service
um and that's a really simple service it
just exposes an HTTP API that we can
query so we could do that directly right
just new up ACP client make the call not
too much work or we could use Dapper
service invocation
um which will offer us some benefits so
if I use Dapper for this I'm not making
a direct call instead of course I'm
calling my local Sidecar then the
sidebar can do surface Discovery so it
can discover where the vehicle
registration service actually runs
it forwards that request for me and then
the remote sidebar will call into the
actual servers and then any response
will flow back the same way
so why codes for all of this trouble
well there are a couple of features that
you get from Deborah
so first of all Dapper can automatically
secure the channel between the sidecar
so it's a little bit added security by
using Mutual TLS
um you also get automatic retries so
whoever is using poly in their.net
services
yeah quote quite a couple of you
um so with Deborah you don't need to
code that yourself you can just create a
retry policy in configuration and your
Dapper sidecars basically do that retry
for you so that's very nice to have
um and then finally because all of that
traffic flows through the sidecar the
sidecars can really help you with
observability and things like
distributor tracing and writing stuff
down to application insights like
analytics so there's some nice benefits
that you uh that you get
so now that we have that information we
can really start sending that email so
for that I'm using a nice application
called Mill Dev who is familiar with
Milda up to two people
um it's really great if you want to test
sending emails because it's basically it
explodes an SMTP server and if you send
some mail to it you can view it in this
really nice UI and you can check if it
works and if the email looks like you
intended to so it's really nice for
debugging and for demos like this
um so I've set up increase for Port 25
for that SMTP so that I can use a SMTP
output binding to send that email now
this binding was actually created by
buddy of mine Android phone back who
wants to try creating a new component
for Dapper it's all open source so if
you know any go or if you don't know any
go because Edwin also didn't know any
girl but if you look at some of the
other components it's not that difficult
to to pick up you can create your own
components and then contribute it back
to the project
so my code again doesn't need to know
anything about SMTP simply going through
that binding
all right
so let me
show you some code for design collection
servers
let's make some room here let's close
this one close close
don't need this
Fine Collection servers program
[Music]
same thing
um
I'm using minimal apis here so to
subscribe to those speeding violation
events I have this event handler and 40
pops up middle 40 pops a building block
I'm using this with topic methods to do
the actual subscription
so here I'm telling Deborah I want to
use the pops up component named pops up
a pretty good name and I want to
subscribe to the spinning violations
topic and then whenever a message comes
in please call this endpoint for me
so in this endpoint
the first thing I do is I get that
license key from uh from configuration
so you may wonder how did that license
key end up in configuration because I
had it stored in the Azure key fold
remember
so we scroll up a bit
then all that magic is being done
through the add Dapper Secret store
extension method here on the
configuration manager so what this does
is I tell it which Secret store I'm
using and then it will get all the
secrets from that store it doesn't have
to be all the secrets by the way if you
just want to get a couple of keys you
can also specify this in an offload the
mic is just getting all these secrets
and it's putting them inside of the net
configuration framework so it's
available as you would normally access
configuration stuff
now this parameter here is a delimiter
that I want to use to create hierarchies
because in.net configuration
has hierarchies so this means that if I
have something like this in my key fault
my connection strings database
oh
double hyphen
um this will get parsed into a
connection string section with the
database key under it and the reason I'm
using double hyphens here is as that
separators because Azure default
actually only supports Alpha numerical
characters and hyphen characters inside
the key names so that will load
everything into.net configuration and
then for my actual code I can just
reference it like this
um all right so now I have the license
key I can use the find calculator to
calculate that find amount
passing in a license key and the
violation I cut back the amount of euros
and now I need to make that call to the
vehicle registration servers with Dapper
service invocation and there are a
couple of ways to do that the way I'm
doing it here is what they recommend
and that's by using a special type of
HTTP client
so I've created ACP client by calling
this debit client create info kcp client
and that will new up an HTTP client for
me but with a very special message
Handler and then message Handler allows
me to use URLs like this
which are really Compact and and
functional so the hostname here in this
URL is the Debra application ID of the
application that I like to call and then
Depot will do the search Discovery and
discover where that application actually
is and then all the other stuff in the
URL is simply the route that I want to
call on that application so what that
message Handler actually does under the
hood is it will take this URL and it
will rewrite it to something like this
to a call on my local sidecar which is
running on 3500 upgrade it's out
completing
saved me from making a lot of typing
errors so it will rewrite it to this way
longer URL which is a call to my local
sidecar and that will perform the actual
request so being able to use just HTTP
client with a shorter URLs is really
nice if you have an existing application
that you want to depth rise because then
most probably only need to chase some
host names here and there and and you're
done
so now that we get back the vehicle info
I can put everything together and inform
a couple of other components that I've
now calculated Define there are more
than one component that wants to know
about this so again I'm going to do this
using events I'm going to create a fine
calculated event which contains that
fine amount and also the email address
and some other stuff like the vehicle
brand and model don't know why that's a
thing but it's in there and then I'm
going to publish that event back to the
surface bus so anyone interested can now
handle that defense and do some cool
stuff with it
any
first component that's interested in
this is actually the fan collection
service itself
um
because this is listening on that fines
topic and it's forwarding calls to
Define calculated endpoint in order to
send that email but now it's nicely
decoupled from each other
so
um here we first create the email body
then we set up some metadata like the
from anniversary to address and subjects
and then I can call the invoke binding
to executed SMTP binding and that will
send the email
so let me see where we are this would
probably be a good time to show you
those emails
and that it actually works
but unfortunately surprise surprise
we're running into that same annoying
issue because this is the nice UI that
Mill deaf gets gives me it's running
somewhere in the environment I've
already cut Port 25 setup for SMTP
increase so I cannot set up a different
port to access my UI
so now I have this UI but again because
only one port can be used for Ingress I
cannot reach it which is pretty annoying
and we'll have to offer engineer another
solution for this so this is another
container map I've created just to
create an alternative dashboard to view
the fines
so it will need to have access to the
fines data as well so the way it's going
to do that it's going to subscribe again
through Dapper Pub sub do the same find
calculated events and then I'll create a
materialized view put it in a Azure SQL
database and I'm just using normal
Entity framework for that so I'm don't
use any Dapper for this we may want to
do some more complex queries in the
future on that data so Azure SQL seems
to be a better fit for that than that
per state management
um
basically then the only thing I have to
do that's left to do is set up increase
for this and then anybody who knows the
URL can see that find data so that's
great
um that's also horrible even for
government agencies this is really bad
security if everybody who knows the URL
can see the fines data so we need to set
up some authorization
now fortunately ACA has this really nice
built-in TurnKey authentication feature
it's sometimes also called easy author
you may recognize this this from Azure
app Services it's basically this the
same feature that I've also offered here
so how this works is when I set this up
I cut some authentication middleware
injected into the request Pipeline and
so that's just another container already
request goes to so if the perhaps makes
a request it first hits that
authentication middleware that will take
care of any of authenticating the
clients and of managing the
authentication sessions and then it will
forward the request to my Thrift control
UI and you can use all kinds of
identity providers with this so I'm
using Azure active directory you can
also use other social logins like Google
Facebook Twitter if that's still a thing
you can basically use any open ID
connects profile here
and then there are two flavors you can
use you can tell the authentication
middleware to only let authenticated
requests true so as long as the user is
authenticated they will never be able to
reach your application or and that's
what I'm doing you can set it to
Anonymous and that means that
unauthentic cage users will also get
through and you can show like a home
page with the login button and stuff
like that
so let me show you what that looks like
um
let me first go to the Irish portal
and then I'm going back to the resource
Group and here is my 12 control UI so
this is the app
and here up in the essentials section
you can see the application URL
so if I go there this is my nice
dashboard let me see let's go in a
little bit
all right so
um there's not much to this dashboard
yet I do have one option here to go to
the fines and as you might expect if I
go to the files I'm not authorized which
is exactly what I want so that's great
so
let me show you how this works in the
code
now the reason I get that unauthorized
is because in the app and by the way
this is a Blazer server app
so on this page
I've decorated I've added the attributes
for authorize so this will check
do we have an authentication token no we
don't so you're not allowed to see this
page right
um
so now we need to create that login code
so it's just going to be difficult nope
um this is really easy so in our main
layout I've just created if you're not
authorized of creating a link going to
dot all slash login slash aad and I
added the aid part because I'm using
Azure active directory
so what this means is
all the requests with DOT auth will get
intercepted by that authentication
middleware and it will take care of all
the oauth
stuff that needs to be done and then
after that's done it will redirect back
to my application
um
so yeah let's let's see if that works so
it's going to be quick because probably
I'm already locked into Azure ID so it
will just bounce back directly or it may
show me a login page let's see what
happens no it's uh it's already detected
it I'm already logged into Azure so now
I'm logged in you can see it knows my
email address that's from a claim in the
in the token so
how does Blazer know
what my claims are right because the
authentication was done by that other
container so how does it get access to
the claims data well that works with a
HTTP request header
so if we go to the very start of my
application
then you can see that I here I try to
get this this XMS client principle
request header from the incoming request
now this is only set if I'm
authenticated
and it's basically a basic C4 encode
adjson documents which contains my token
and all of the claims that are set
um
now due to the way that Blazer server
works you cannot simply access the acdp
context from anywhere your application
so they recommend that you do it in the
OCS HTML so here I try to detect if
we've got that principle and if we do I
deserialize it I parsed into this Ms
client principal object and I pass it
into my application using this parameter
syntax here and that will inject it into
this app.racer
and here when my application initializes
I use my own authentication State
provider so this is an object that well
does as it says on the tin it provides
authentication states to to Blazer and
I've created my own called easy all
state provider so what this does
I said we'll check if that client
principle was set
if it is we can create a new claims
identity using all those claims and all
that information coming originally from
that header
if it wasn't set we're unauthorized we
just create an empty claims identity and
Blaze will recognize that as
unauthorized
and then we wrap this and identity sorry
into a principle and then we wrap
authentication State around that
principle and that we return to Blazer
and now Blazer knows about our claims
and it knows if we're authorized or not
so coming back
we can now go to Defiance page and this
will work now let me just add some load
on this so I'm going back
here we should see
mostly most of time it takes a couple of
seconds for somebody to drive too fast
but if August will then yeah there is a
new one
and it's going pretty good actually I
think we are almost at two grand right
now since I've started uh testing these
demo so yeah it's a lucrative business
um all right
I think
um just
about a time so let me quickly wrap this
up so all in all I'm um I really like
Azure container apps I also really like
uh Debra but there are some definite
limitations with the combination of
those two
um so first of all and actually the most
annoying of all is that single board
inquest that really took me by surprise
if I'm hitting it two times in a what is
a pretty simple demo scenario and if I
think through some of the production
scenarios and my clients I can think of
a lot of uh examples where single port
simply isn't good enough
um there is some discussion in the
GitHub issues about this more people
wanting this but as far as I know it's
not on the official world map yet but
keep fingers crossed
um then the other pretty big limitation
is around configuration so all of the
configuration I've shown you is at the
component level it's for configuring
components but there's an entirely other
level of configuration in Dapper which
is called the application configuration
and you use that to set some Advanced
features like you you want to use some
preview features or you want to specify
which sources allowed to call which
other services we want to inject your
own custom middleware in between your
application and your sidecar and those
are nice and useful features but I can't
use those because ACA doesn't allow me
to specify my own configuration file now
they may
servers these features in different kind
of way make make it accessible without
you having to specify a complete
configuration file but most of these
things here aren't available yet to use
in in Asia yet
and very quickly the final thing is I
cannot specify which version of Deborah
I want to run
um which may or may not be a big problem
for you
um so right now they are running I think
what's this uh 195 or 196 the latest
version and I believe I've read
somewhere in GitHub issues that they aim
to go to the new version like three to
four weeks after the latest deprivation
has been released but in the past there
definitely has been some breaking
changes in Dapper so
I start to wonder what if I'm running my
production system and then they decide
to upgrade from debra1. whatever to
Dapper 2 is my system still going to
work or am I going to have to deal with
breaking changes so ideally I do not
only want to have a deeper enabled or
disabled Taco but ideally I want to
specify which version I can I'm using in
my Azure container environment
um
all of that said this is basically still
pretty early days uh the team is
iterating pretty fast with new features
uh so yeah it's going to be an
interesting year to see if some of this
will get on the roadmap
um so now I'm definitely at time and I
don't want to keep you from lunch uh so
thank you so much for joining uh me
today all of the source code is
available on my GitHub if you want to
know more about Dapper I've written a
free ebook which is available on the
Microsoft site I'm a co-author along
with two other guys and I also have
this.net video webcast thingy which you
may also like so thank you very much and
if I create rest of the conference
oh and by the way if there are any
questions I'll be here for the um well
coming minutes uh and I'm here all week
so just find me at a conference if you
if you want to chat